.
>>> ALSO IN THE POLITICS LEAD, A
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE
SUPPORTED BY DONALD TRUMP BY THE
WAY WHOSE PAST WRITINGS AND
ASSOCIATIONS INDICATE HE'S
AGAINST WOMEN VOTING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT JOHN GIBBS.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER HIM BECAUSE
WITH SOME FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE WITH ADS, WE
THOUGHT HE WOULD BE AN EASIER
CANDIDATE FOR THEIR DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE TO BEAT.
HE DEFEATED REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN PETER MYER IN THE
PRIMARY.
MYER VOTED TO IMPEACH DONALD
TRUMP.
THE SENIOR EDITOR OF THE K FILE
JOINS US NOW.
WHAT HAVE YOU FOUND?
>> GIBBS IS A FORMER TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL WHO IN
THE EARLY 2000s RAN THIS THINK
TANK CALLED THE SOCIETY FOR THE
CRITIQUE OF FEMINISM AND IT
BASICALLY ARGUED SEVERAL THINGS.
ONE OF WHICH IS THE U.S. GREATLY
SUFFERED FROM WOMEN HAVING THE
RIGHT TO VOTE, THAT WOMEN DID
NOT POSSESS, YOU KNOW, THE
NECESSARY QUALITIES TO GOVERN
AND THAT WOMEN SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO BE IN THE WORKPLACE.
>> SO ON THE WEBSITE HE GAVE
SPECIFIC REASONS WHY WOMEN
SHOULD NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE?
>> YEAH, HE MAKES THIS ARGUMENT
THAT THE 19th AMENDMENT THAT
ALLOWED WOMEN TO VOTE, HE SAYS
IT'S BEEN UNEQUIVOCALLY BAD FOR
THE UNITED STATES AND LED THE
SIZE AND WE CONCLUDE THAT THE
U.S. SUFFERED AS A RESULT OF
WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE.
ON A FEW OTHER OCCASIONS, AS
WELL, HE ALSO PRAISED AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS ACTIVELY
TRYING TO REPEAL THE 19th
AMENDMENT.
HIS TEAM CALLED THIS
ORGANIZATION GREAT.
HE EVEN WROTE THEM AN EMAIL THEY
POSTED ON THEIR WEBSITE IN THE
EARLY 2000s THAT SAID YOU HAVE
MY SUPPORT.
>> AND HIS WEBSITE WAS ALSO
CRITICAL OF WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE?
>> HIS WEBSITE WAS REALLY
CRITICAL OF WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE.
IT'S SORT OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT,
YOU KNOW, GENERALIZED SORT OF
SEXISM THAT YOU MIGHT HEAR.
HE BASICALLY SAID WITH WOMEN IN
THE WORKPLACE, HIS QUOTE IS MEN
BASICALLY HAVE TO BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO AVOID OFFENDING
WOMEN, YOU KNOW, HE ARGUED THAT
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE LED TO
FRIVOLOUS SEXUAL HARASSMENT
LAWSUITS AND MEN COULDN'T MAKE
AS MANY JOKES.
>> HOW IS THE GIBBS CAMPAIGN
RESPONDING TO YOUR REPORTING?
>> SO WE REACHED OUT TO THE
GIBBS CAMPAIGN YESTERDAY.
THEY TOLD US HE MADE THIS
WEBSITE TO PROVOKE THE LEFT AND
MODERN DAY FEMINISTS SAYING THIS
IS NOTHING MORE THAN A COLLEGE
STUDENT BEING OVER THE TOP.